monsieur le premier ministre vous
déclariez en novembre 2015 que vous
souhaitiez que les sanctions puissent
être levés contre la russie un mois
après les sanctions fut reconduite alors
aujourd'hui on assiste à un bal de
déclaration de vos ministres monsieur
macron qu'il ya quelques semaines à
moscou déclaré qu'il souhaitait que ces
sanctions soient levées
monsieur le foll lui aussi qui s'est
positionné en faveur de la levée de ces
sanctions qui frappent durant notre
agriculture française et à chaque fois
en nous disant ces sanctions doivent
être levée si les accords de minsk sont
respectées
regardons la réalité en face aujourd'hui
les accords de minsk ont permis une
réduction notable des affrontements
militaires
même si les observateurs de l'ouest se
constate chaque semaine des violations
du cessez le feu par chacune des deux
parties mais surtout les réformes
institutionnelles promise par l'ukraine
n'ont toujours pas un an après été votée
d'ailleurs le 23 février dernier jean
marc ayrault et frank walter steinmeier
appelé l'ukraine a enfin voté ces
réformes prévues aux accords de minsk
de toute évidence il n'y a quasiment
aucune chance que ces réformes
favorisant l'autonomie de certaines
régions soit votée parce que le
parlement ukrainien n'a désormais plus
aucune majorité
bref les accords de 1100 dans une
impasse et pendant ce temps là nos
agriculteurs souffle nos entreprises
perdent des marchés alors monsieur
leproux monsieur le premier ministre
ma question est donc simple dans trois
mois ces sanctions devront être
renouvelés ces sanctions ne peuvent être
renouvelé que s'il ya unanimité des pays
européens ce qui veut dire que ne vous
abritez pas derrière les autres vous
avez la réponse entre vos mains
alors ma question est donc simple dans
trois mois est-ce que vous choisirez de
défendre les intérêts de nos
agriculteurs les intérêts de nos
entreprises
les intérêts de la france merci la
parole comme monsieur mathias fekl
secrétaire d'état chargée du commerce
extérieur la promotion du tourisme et
des français de l'étranger
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
thierry mariani vous interroger le
gouvernement sur la situation en russie
sur notre axe
diplomatique et aussi sur l'impact
économique de cette situation nous avons
eu à plusieurs reprises la possibilité
d'échanger là-dessus y compris en
commission c'est un sujet important et
je veux vous dire d'abord que dans qui
mérite un peu d'attention
je veux vous dire d'abord que sur vos
deux aînés qui ont été posées quitter la
réforme totalement son rôle de grande
nation diplomatique son rôle de membre
permanent du conseil de sécurité et son
rôle de puissance souhaitant garantir la
paix aux frontières de l'europe
et oui avec l'allemagne avec toutes les
parties prenantes nous sommes engagés
dans le processus de minsk pour que la
paix y reviennent et pour que toutes les
parties mettent pleinement en oeuvre le
processus de minsk et les accords de
minsk sur l'impact économique de cette
situation je rappelle d'abord que les
relations commerciales entre la france
et la russie avaient commencé à baisser
bien avant les embargos qui ont commencé
pour l'embargo sanitaire en février
épaule embargo politique en août 2014
puisque depuis de yves au pc vos
populations elles et de la demande
intérieure russe a baissé de 35% en
raison de l'évolution des prix des
hydrocarbures et de la dépréciation du
rouble
nous sommes mobilisés avec stéphane le
foll qui était à moscou à la fin de
l'année dernière avec emmanuel macron
qui était il ya quelques semaines et
avec moi qui serai dans quelques
semaines pour obtenir à la fois un
travail avec la russie et aussi des
débouchés alternatif pour nos
agriculteurs nous avons déjà obtenu de
nombreuses ouvertures de marché à cet
égard nous continuerons avec la
diplomatie des terroirs à travailler sur
ce sujet pour défendre l'agriculture
française et travail et merci merci
monsieur fécales
allez s'il vous plaît on retrouve un peu
de calme et on écoute la question de
monsieur david